cameron in alabama you're on the bench
bo struggle for camera
okay bed um I just want to say first off
that you're one of my inspirations and I
really enjoyed your regulative history
book oh thank you sister for you today
my my question for you today is go the
awful odor coronavirus topic counts and
a little bit more of cultural level what
is your um what is your view on the like
what's your advice for someone like my
I'm 27 years old and you know we're
living in sort of what I believe is a
relaxed sex culture what is your like
what is your advice on that suit because
I feel like we're used you know you said
a long time ago at a young American
foundation that you know people use sex
as being disposable it was curious like
what was your but what's your advice for
someone in my age now in the dating
world obviously right now obviously it's
not a good idea because of the corona
virus but in general yeah well I mean I
will say that that I have never seen a
better a better attempt to dissuade
casual sexual encounters than
coronavirus it's pretty if that was
God's plan I'm not sure I like the plan
God but it's it's effective it's very
effective like human beings just never
seeing each other ever again but in any
case you know as far as the general
tenor as I've said if you want to date
at these times and you are dating for
something more than that then you really
ought to be dating in a religious
context or the very least in a committed
context and you can do that by simply
saying straight upfront with with the
girl that you are interested in a
committed relationship and then
tailoring your conversations toward that
commitment everybody thinks that finding
TV shows in common or things you like to
do together like that's that that's the
most important stuff here's the truth
90% of people like TV 90% of people like
Disneyland 90% of people like long walks
on the beach right that most people have
like things that are fun in common but
guess what marriage actually and end
dating these are not actually times when
you spend 90% of your time doing fun
stuff one of the things that I always
found weird about shows like the
bachelor or the Bachelorette is they
better call the best way to know
somebody scored a hot air balloon ride
with them and I think like I have never
been ever on a hot air balloon ride with
my wife like ever nor are these people
if they ever got married going to spend
more than one day out of
presumably in the next 60 years in a
hot-air balloon and why in the world are
you tailoring all of these dates to like
things that will never happen again nor
would they ever happen in real life you
know what real life is like if you want
to date seriously real life is you go
and you see the person every single day
and you sit next to them when they are
working and you talk with them and you
got lunch with them and you hang out
with them and you go do favors for them
and you get to know them really well so
I did in my wife for about three months
three and a half months before we got
engaged we started dating September 5th
of 2007 and septum yeah 2007 and we got
MIT and we got engaged on December 22nd
of 2007 so whatever that period is
that's that that was our total dating
time before we got engaged and honestly
it was a pretty packed time because I
made a commitment after the first couple
of weeks when we dated you know once
every 34 days I made a commitment that I
was gonna go and see her every single
day and so after work I would go now and
see her every single day
and if she had to work in the library at
UCLA I would literally bring her a meal
and I would sit there and I would do my
work on one side of the table and she
would do her work on the other side of
the table and I wouldn't bother her cuz
she had work to do and then we would
take a break for 15 minutes and hang out
and go back and doing work or if she
really you know needed to focus I would
drop the meal and I would leave cuz you
know what that's kind of like what
marriage is that kind of is what
marriage is I haven't seen my wife at
this point for a month like I'm not
kidding for the last month I've not seen
my wife since our baby was born I have
not seen her at all why well because
number one she is keeping odd hours cuz
she has to nurse the baby number two I
have two other kids one got the flu then
a week later another got the flu which
means I have to keep them both separate
from my wife and the baby so the baby
doesn't get the flu so I've seen my wife
in the last month for a combined total
of approximately 7.2 minutes but the
reason that the relationship can survive
that is because I have the security of
knowing that life was like that before
and I spent all sorts of time with her
you know what's the thing we're not
doing right now going on a hot-air
balloon so if you are worried about you
know dating for commitment then think
about dating for commitment in realistic
ways as opposed to what's the most
romantic thing I can think of for every
single date what if I spread a rose
petal laying down the down the middle of
Main Street and Disneyland every single
like that's not real life
so make dating more like real life and
then you're more likely to get a partner
that you want for real wise okay thank
you very much man I really appreciate it
again you're a real inspiration to me
and I follow the daily wire
it's basically one of my main news
sources and it's awesome Thank You
Cameron really appreciate the call Jim
in Illinois you're on the bench pure
glow for Ken hey Ben I have a question
about Cove in 19 so I'm from Illinois
and obviously our economy it's pretty
much already a trash chute our governor
has already said that we were hurting
- just keep unemployment benefits up
because somebody does their closing so
in your opinion should we keep
everything locked up in people inside
their houses or will there come a day
when we're just going to have to open
things back up and let the disease kind
of spread and get immunity has horrible
as that may sound I mean I think that
once we hit the summer we're gonna have
to open things back up and then the
really what nobody is saying is that the
great hope is that by early May mid May
that we that the virus wanes because it
is burned through either a lot of the
population already or because summer
kills it off or that we developed some
sort of mitigating medications or that
we have increased our ICU and
ventilators so much that you know the
people who need treatment can get
treatment but there's virtually nobody
who expects that we're going to prevent
tons and tons of people from getting
this over the course of the next year I
mean this is something I've been harping
on which is that none of the models
suggest that people are avoiding getting
it right now are not gonna get it in the
fall so the question is how long can we
keep this up what's the purpose of it
presumably the purpose is to buy us some
time so we can deal with it but yes
people are going to go back to work I
think all of the talk about how we're
gonna have mass testing in tens of
thousands of tests and serology tests so
we know who's immune and all this I
can't see that being ramped up fast
enough for summer I think that no
likelihood we go to sort of a
rough-and-ready style of employment
where everybody goes back to work people
continue to social distance if you can
work from home you continue to work from
home and if you are under the age of 65
or under the age of 60 and you don't
have pre-existing conditions we're gonna
assume you don't have the virus if you
do get sick you go home for 14 days and
that's pretty much how things go up
until we have a vaccine because this is
not sustainable it just is not we're not
going to be locked up for the next for
the next year 12 to 18 months until we
have a vaccine good luck good luck I so
it will come to an end I'm hoping that
the mitigating efforts are enough but
it's you know it's it could be ugly for
the next few months I do not think this
is going to extend again I've talked to
you at this point probably dozens of
doctors
I would say that virtually everybody
agrees that by early summer people are
gonna be getting back to work in some
shape fashion reform so I just in by
early summer they mean like tail end of
May early June perfect thank you so much
for taking my call I really appreciate
it
alrighty Renee in Chicago you're on the
bench pure short Renee hey Ben thank you
so much for having me I'm a big I'm a
big fan of yours but I wanted to call in
just to say I feel like I would like you
to provide a little more perspective I
feel like you're not in my personal
opinion of the governmental response to
the virus that we're all experiencing
and balance that out and compared with
the economic impact to all the lockdown
as well as the rationale behind those
lifestyles being primarily from what I'm
seeing being based on models and all of
the information that that's coming out
when folks are come contrasting the
projection for hospitalizations ICU beds
for example the actuals are coming in
are way under what the production models
of thing coming in so in my opinion
that's not that strong of a rationale to
take away basic Liberty I'm in Illinois
we're in completely lockdown and I feel
like the models themselves are not as
strong enough rationale so I feel like
that's not really being talked about on
your show or any show really well I mean
actually I spent the entirety of the
first hour of the show and all of
today's podcast on this because it's
exactly what I'm concerned about too is
that these models are being trotted out
there with a level of certainty that is
not of benefit given the the lack of
data at this point now again lack of
data doesn't mean that we should all
just run out there willy-nilly but it
does mean that we should be thinking
every day about what points we have
enough data where we can start talking
about opening this thing back up
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content